right here
has spent 20 days stuck at the Sudanese
Egyptian border after fleeing the
fighting between the Army and the rapid
support forces in Khartoum
she thought it would be easy for her and
her six children to cross the border
into Egypt
the new rules came as a surprise
the consulate said that they would let
mothers with only three of their
children enter this is a big problem how
can I go with only three of my children
what about the others
hanum and many other women are sleeping
in one of the mosques in wadihalfa which
has been turned into a temporary shelter
[Music]
we have been forced from our homes only
to be humiliated and frustrated this is
the life of Sudanese now
we're in a very difficult situation I
will dive I have to endure this for two
or three more days
I have nothing but this sheet how do I
cook where do I eat or drink how can I
take a shower what should I do just sit
here why are the Egyptians doing this to
us I want to know why
every day thousands of people Gather in
front of the Egyptian consulate hoping
to get visas
a scene that reflects the magnitude of
the tragedy
until recently women children and the
elderly didn't need visas to cross the
border
not anymore
many Sudanese say that despite meeting
all the conditions their applications
are rejected
after a long day at the consulate hanum
returns with all her papers hoping
she'll have better luck next time
I just came from the consulate without
getting a Visa
there are many aspects to the suffering
here the temporary accommodation lacks
basic facilities and the cost of renting
a bed is Out Of Reach for most
no humanitarian agencies are operating
in the area and people say they're
running out of supplies
Sudan